[Musique]
à quoi tu penses je fais ce que je fais
à cause de mon père c'était un héros il
a sacrifié sa vie dans sa quête du
savoir contrôler nos capés ça avant
[Musique]
c'est la folle edwards et des incendies
partout des avions qui s'écrasent
ils appellent ça la surcharge comment
doha nous disposons d'informations
botman confidentielles que pouvez vous
nous dire du projet lima qu'il avait
pour but de trouver une vie extra
terrestre avancé le vaisseau a disparu
environ 16 ans après son lancement et au
sujet de son capitaine
c'était mon père mon général
cela risque de vous faire un sacré show
n'est votre père menait des expériences
sur un matériau top secrets susceptibles
de menacer tout notre système solaire et
de détruire toute vie
nous comptons sur francs pour découvrir
tout ce qui se passe je me fais du souci
pour tous j'étais voyez comment c'est
votre expertise psychologique
décrivez du mieux que vous pouvez votre
état mental et émotionnel actuelle je me
sens bien prêt à donner le meilleur de
moi-même pour ce travail
je reste absolument résolu à accomplir
la mission dans les règles
si nécessaire je détruirai le projet de
fond en comble
la terre avait placé ses espoirs en
lutte
or mais c'est à moi
qu'elle confie son destin
nous avons un travail à faire es tu prêt
je suis prêt
[Musique]